[Applause]
and I was kinda like what an idea
in the past year a powerful new
technology has emerged do you buy a
savvy investment in a thriving business
it's what enables the faceswap videos
you may have seen on social media but
some believe it will have far more
profound implications for politics and
society that software powered by
artificial intelligence can now create
wholly fake images video and audio
they're called deep figs and they are
increasingly indistinguishable from
reality which one do you think is fake
can I can i watch them again
literally all look real neato watch it
again can you spot the fake three of
these video clips or of the real
barackobama
one of them was entirely generated by a
computer to test the current state of
this technology we showed people on the
Venice Beach Boardwalk these clips to
see if they could spot the deep fake
this is a totally fake video for most in
all of our minds has been the loss and
the grief I visited with the families of
many of the victims on Thursday as deep
fakes get more realistic pundits and
lawmakers say we need to take action to
control this scary new tech they could
be anybody from a transnational group to
cyber hoodlums and and vigilantes and we
are not ready for it we are not ready
for it they claim that the rise of deep
fakes will bring to an end the very idea
of generally accepted truth saying is no
longer believing we are entering into a
future where anything can be faked well
then nothing is going to be real
you can literally manipulate the news as
it happens in this dystopian future even
a 4chan using basement dweller could
alter the course of international
politics they could have me say things
like President Trump is a total and
complete [ __ ] does it scare you yeah
we were fooled a recent Pew poll found
that 77% of Americans think the
government needs to step in and restrict
altered or made-up videos or images do
you think that the government should
make that a crime yeah I do think so as
long as it doesn't infringe as long as
that doesn't bleed over for you know
creative laws but does this technology
really represent an unprecedented
assault on truth that requires new
restrictions on speech what the most
breathless predictions overlook is that
deep fakes are just the latest extension
of a tradition of manipulation that goes
back to the earliest days of captured
and recorded media deep fakes not only
don't pose a threat to society the
technology has many exciting potential
applications that could be stymied by
legal restrictions now it's true that
deep vix are getting more realistic and
easier to create from stay wolf [ __ ]
using a single selfie from a user
Chinese apps out can replace a celebrity
in a movie scene with anyone holding a
smartphone Stanford researchers have
developed an algorithm that can edit
talking head interviews as easily as
text subtracting or adding words the
subject never really uttered I love the
smell of napalm in the morning I love
the smell of french toast in the morning
and several companies have unveiled
software that can sample just seconds or
minutes of someone's voice I kiss my
dogs
and my wife and then put any words into
that person's mouth that can be typed
into a computer I kiss Dourdan three
times I've had their faces plastered on
other women's bodies and pornographic
videos
redditors recently started posting
videos that superimposed celebrities
into porn scenes using a product called
fake app and the short-lived app deep
nude allowed users to virtually undress
a celebrity or anyone else
I think the technology's definitely
scary reddit and other sites quickly
banned these concoctions and many deep
fake software providers limit the
availability of their tools on ethical
grounds but many people we spoke to
think only the state has the power to
halt the spread of deep fakes I'd like
to think that if this is a concern for
the people that our government would
take
the right sides the protective so-called
deep fakes that enable malicious actors
to foment chaos division or crisis what
you have is not a threat to our
elections but a threat to our republic
constitutional crisis unlike we have
ever faced in the modern history of this
country the house is considering
legislation called the deep fakes
Accountability Act or the defending each
and every person from false appearances
by keeping exploitation subject to
Accountability Act which would make it a
crime to post both synthetic media
unless it's labeled by a removable
digital watermarks it's kind of like
South Park so I mean you know in South
Park that that's not who it's being
portrayed to be I don't know there's a
weird gray area I do think it should be
illegal but at the same time people
should uh do you think it's possible to
make it illegal without sucking up stuff
like that that's a time so I think so
but the proposed law would be impossible
to enforce without also ensnaring vast
amounts of benign and creative speech
the bill is vague as to what should
count as synthetic media and its
response to software that can alter any
image is to make it a crime to post
images that can be altered by software
to remove watermarks you're the
government you're trying to you know
define what a deep fake is so that you
can ban it or you can regulate it how'd
you define it as long as the parties
involved are all informed and consensual
then it's fine
but if I don't know because then we're
going back to the South Park thing where
it's free it's free used like let's say
for example I take this video and I put
your face into the Avengers
should it be banned yeah yeah it should
be banned because like I said you didn't
have my consent but then it is there
already laws like that yes there are
existing defamation libel and fraud laws
already make it a crime to knowingly lie
about what someone said or did to cause
them harm and those civil libertarians
debate their constitutionality revenge
porn laws do exist in most states
explicitly banning the posting of sexual
content without the subjects consent
proposed regulations on deep fakes thus
inherently take aim at certain types of
speech regardless of any actual harm
come on
so how would law makers use new powers
to restrict so-called synthetic media
our
and viral video featuring House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi put the question to the
test President Trump tweeted out a video
of the House Speaker that was edited the
clips were slowed down to make the
congresswoman sound intoxicated give
this president the opportunity to
something historic Facebook marked the
clip as doctored and limited its
distribution
but when executives refused Pelosi's
demands to remove it from the platform
altogether she called them quote willing
and neighbors of the Russian
interference in our election that video
was not an A I assisted deep fake but
rather a crude manual manipulation that
some have called a cheap fake
nonetheless the video's virality and
social media demonstrates the scale of
the challenge we face the Pelosi clip
also demonstrates how lawmakers would
quickly take aim at non-synthetic media
as such low-tech fakes can be just as
convincing so what makes deep fakes a
unique threat to the truth
some argue that their spread will enable
politicians to dismiss every major
caught on video moment as a fake you can
do anything whatever you grab them by
the [ __ ] infamous Access Hollywood tape
is doctored that this is a fake tape
president Trump's recent attempt to spin
his notorious Access Hollywood
appearance as fakery has only fueled
this fire alarmist conjurer future in
which even scenes of presidential
inaugurations could become a battle of
discerning whose video is real this was
the largest audience to ever witness an
inauguration period actually that
already happened in 2017 in fact none of
these worries are new nor are the calls
for government intervention
photographers have been convincingly
altering depictions of reality since the
invention of the media including for
political reasons for example Stalin's
right hand men Nikolai Jakov was
famously erased from this photo
following his execution so you'd rather
see them police it then people learn to
question sources of things due to many
dumb people out a man I don't think you
can I think you can trust people to be
able to recognize it all the time radio
was also once considered a medium for
dumb people because it was piped
directly into American living rooms some
feared that it would drown out the more
sober reporting you might find in
newspapers but this occurrence possibly
has something to do with the
in the planet mark after Orson Welles is
radio broadcast of the War of the Worlds
in 1938 tricked some listeners into
believing there was an actual alien
attack newspapers seized on the incident
to rally support behind restrictions on
the scary new technology similar calls
have followed the emergence of new
technologies from the Telegraph to the
internet fake video going viral on
social media the real image on the right
and the tearing up a target post not the
Constitution a bill to cut down on
photoshopping of models in magazines do
you think that this represents sort of a
fundamental shift in manipulation of
news that Photoshop or deceptive editing
in the past the same thing people still
believe photoshopped pictures as well do
you think there should be similar rules
for like Photoshop photos yeah most of
the people we spoke with including those
who favor legal restrictions on deep
fakes have adapted to the existence of
photo editing software and no longer
view it as a threat to the nature of
truth that requires government
intervention do you think things like
photoshopped photos should also be
regulated in the same way no there's
always gonna be someone they're gullible
enough to believe but usually they're
gonna believe whatever they advocate and
to be honest I wouldn't care if the
person's fake if the news is correct
because a lot of times we get the
correct person but the fake news which
would you rather have it's horrible for
us to have to like question everything
we see on the news online it's like is
that real or is this fake news but you
should question so I got some more
people know about deep fakes like the
better because then you know the
question yeah
the technology behind deep fakes could
allow real time language translation and
video chat each village or give back a
voice to people who have lost theirs to
illnesses like ALS I want to say like me
it could help actors aged up or down for
movie roles and create opportunities for
underrepresented indigent or disabled
artists laws supposedly targeting deep
fakes could stymie these and other
exciting potential applications and they
could also give powerful people the
ability to censor any content they find
embarrassing you want to keep your money
freedom deep fix maybe the latest front
in media manipulation but like the
people we interviewed most consumers
have adapted to past technological leaps
and will continue to do so and just as
technology enabling deep fakes is
advancing so is technology that can
identify them software and development
can analyze metadata and the video
itself using AI to detect subtle signs
of manipulation and the company amber
uses cryptography in the blockchain to
verify the time and location video is
captured as well as its content these
tools are hardly foolproof but they'll
continue to get better even so software
already exists to spot realistic fake
images made with programs like Photoshop
but the people we talked to said they
still find tried-and-true media literacy
strategies more useful a lot of people
like will send me something and they'll
be like look and I'm like that doesn't
seem right and so if I think it's like
something weird I'll like google it and
like look it up
I do like every other good person I
google it or I snoop it or I called the
local drunk down the street who's going
to the barbershop cuz he knows
everything but the main thing I do is I
will go and check for other sources do
you think that you could still do that
for deep fix without having to have the
government regulate it yeah like it's
there for me to do if I want to do it
and really really figure out so
Americans may want to reconsider whether
there really is a coming techno
apocalypse that will send society into a
tailspin of lies perhaps this brave new
world isn't really all that different
than those that have come before and
whether the fakes are obvious and it
will be huge or subtle for most in all
of our minds media consumers can and
will adapt you believe what you want to
believe you find what you look for if
somebody wants to believe that Hillary
Clinton was in a threesome with Donald
Trump and a boa constrictor they'll
believe it it's up to you to determine
whether it's faker true and look a
little deeper
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]